let's say we have a hypothetical
reaction where reactant a turns into
products
and let's say the reaction is second
order with respect to a if the reaction
is second order with respect to a then
we can write the rate of the reaction is
equal to the rate constant k times the
concentration of a to the second power
since this is a second order reaction
we can also write the rate of the
reaction is equal to the negative of the
change in the concentration of a over
the change in time
if we set these two ways of writing the
rate of reaction equal to each other and
use some calculus including the concept
of integration we'll arrive at the
integrated rate law for a second order
reaction
the integrated rate law for a second
order reaction says that one over the
concentration of reactant a at some time
t is equal to the rate constant k times
the time plus 1 over
the initial concentration of a
notice how the integrated rate law has
the form of y is equal to
m x plus b which is the equation for a
straight line
so if we graph one over the
concentration of a on the y-axis
and time on the x-axis so let's go ahead
and put that in here 1 over the
concentration of a on the y-axis
and time on the x-axis we will get a
straight line and the slope of that line
is equal to the rate constant k
so slope
is equal to k
and the y-intercept is equal to 1 over
the initial concentration of a so the
point where our line intersects the
y-axis
is equal to one over
the initial concentration of a
let's look at an example of a second
order reaction
c5h6
is
cyclopentadiene and two molecules of
cyclopentadiene will react with each
other to form dicyclopentadiene
our goal is to use the data from this
data table to prove that this reaction
is second order
however we have to be careful because in
our balanced equation we have a two as a
coefficient in front of cyclopentadiene
going back to our hypothetical reaction
where reactant a turned into products
there was a 1 as a coefficient in front
of the a and if there's a 1 as a
coefficient in front of the a we can use
this form of the integrated rate law for
a second order reaction
however for our problem we have a two as
a coefficient in front of
cyclopentadiene
and that means we need to have a
stoichiometric coefficient of one half
in here
and that changes the math now when we
set these two rates of reactions equal
to each other and we use calculus and we
integrate to get our integrated rate law
because of this one half
we end up with a 2 in front of the k
so thinking about y is equal to
m x plus
b
now the slope of the line is equal to
2k
so now for our reaction we can write our
integrated rate law as one over the
concentration of cyclopentadiene at some
time t
is equal to two kt plus one over the
initial concentration of cyclopentadiene
so if we look at our data table we have
time in seconds and we have the
concentration of cyclopentadiene
but we need to have one over the
concentration of cyclopentadiene so we
need a new column so we're going to
calculate 1 over
the concentration of
cyclopentadiene
so if the concentration of
cyclopentadiene when time is equal to 0
seconds is point zero four zero zero
molar if we take one one divided by
point zero
four zero zero
we would get
twenty five
point
to save some time i've gone ahead and
filled in the rest of this column notice
as time increases so as we go from zero
seconds to 50 to 100 to 150 to 200 the
concentration of cyclopentadiene
decreases because cyclopentadiene is
turning into dicyclopentadiene
next we need to graph our data so we're
going to have 1 over the concentration
of cyclopentadiene on the y-axis and
time on the x-axis our first point so
when time is equal to zero one over the
concentration of cyclopentadiene is 25.0
so if we go down to our graph
we can see that when time is equal to
zero our first point here is
25.0 and plotting the other points gives
us a straight line
next we need to find the slope of this
straight line
and there are many ways to do that one
way to do it is to use a graphing
calculator
and when i used a graphing calculator to
find the slope of this line i found that
the slope is equal to
point
one six three four
thinking about y is equal to m x
plus b our slope should be equal to
two k
so to find the rate constant k we need
to
divide the slope by two
which gives us
point
.0817
[Music]
to find the units for k remember that
slope is equal to change in y
over change in x and on our y-axis our
units are one over molar and the x-axis
the units are seconds
so therefore we can write the rate
constant k is equal to .0817
[Music]
to be one over molar divided by seconds
was which is the same thing as one over
molar times seconds
it's important to point out that most
textbooks don't cover
how the two as a coefficient changes
changes the integrated rate law and so a
lot of textbooks will simply say that
the slope of the line for the second
order integrated rate law is equal to k
so a lot of books would just say the
final answer for the rate constant is
0.163
so you'll see you'll see a lot of
textbooks say that the rate constant
would be 0.163
1 over molar times
seconds
however since the coefficient in front
of cyclopentadiene is a 2
technically technically this rate
constant is the correct one
finally since
we got a straight line
when we graphed one over the
concentration of cyclopentadiene versus
time we know that this reaction has
second order kinetics